hello welcome to senior playing um jus
Ghana are you got ah ok is this a little
brother of whole game I blyton p3 maybe
yeah they never know ok i'm shooting for
this one yeah this is not a bad line for
black i think this kind of setup let's
do this you probably take night f5 looks
kind of weird um yeah anyway I've gained
a couple of points in the last video in
the last opponent I disconnected after a
couple of moves so if I didn't make a
video out of that felt a little bit
pointless okie dokie what's this yeah
probably just take him I would give my
bishop is better off on d6 here but
still it's not bad and got a very nice
easy development him Bishop g4 is a good
move to come which prevents ok I cannot
take only three air think sometimes
possible stuff like that I wonder if
Bishop e3 is a move trading this
definitely not a bad wolf ok let's do it
I've got very easy development TM brook
to the aid / possibly c5c for ideas like
that white has this central majority and
four against three but I'm not sure that
this netsim much so I development is so
good that give way I don't mind that I
have c5 later Queen wants to swing over
to g5 anyway so what to h5 not sure
about it hmm
ok let's look at e3 first so that f flow
becomes less of an option guess what I
wanted to provoke but I probably didn't
doesn't do much right doesn't do what
hmm
yeah that doesn't really do anything
Green g6
Jay was Jupiter doesn't didn't help at
all let's just go away then I thought I
can do something on the King side but
this is just a complete illusion
c5 is also not in not an ideal square by
any stretch of the imagination but it's
what it is and I put something on c3
here we lost that interesting isn't this
a little bit annoying before no don't
think that before helps them I'm ok with
going to see for I guess
this is not a specialty exciting yeah
it's hard Jetta trader probably have to
yeah it feels very equal I maybe can
actually play rugby one year it would be
interesting shooting form to d7 you know
okay
slightly ad on the clock at least
position is just equal there should be a
three interesting
trying to improve my back rank a little
bit shifty 7b six and identify this idea
okay interesting okay I mean Chad no
that's a nice ending yeah it still s
amino came a nice ending it's rather
coolish still has some pawns on light
squares but it's probably not a big deal
grah i heard young probably am probably
the draw any way forward him probably
not time morning not but i don't see how
i lose really so let's try
yes if I it's completely blocked after
that okay okay I don't have a way
forward him fortunately she falls
probably playing more for loss than for
anything else ha ha ha I'll grab him hey
I cannot do anything I tried but it was
ultimately very solid yeah it says good
game probably it was a good game I mean
it felt like it was pretty equal ish all
along the way yeah probably my idea on
the Kings side were kind of naive I went
back and now there's not much going on
oops so for that yeah that generates do
we Knight to c3 didn't didn't do
anything it's prob that just very chan I
mean at first you think that white might
have something with this four against
three on the King side but he doesn't
get a passive and I have some insurances
here on those poems hear their own light
squares so this is why I why he went for
this getting rid of the pawns I cannot
do much him maybe I can play with our c5
trying to lay that a little bit but it's
a draw i guess it just and just pretty
pretty equal ok well thanks for watching